all right looking black party oh you can
barely hear anything goddammit I done
because you're lagging all by to subdued
buddy
go turn back from court when tonight ha
we all right that'll have to do
okay I'm just cheat cheat pieces of the
all yelled put it get it telex have you
found a blog Stingo
the what the blood-stained boat oh yeah
now we're gonna get that now no problem
family yeah I know what it is it's an
obvious spot I can't believe I missed it
to be honest it's right in this funnel
it should all got it and now we got cook
it in the microwave it should be here
yeah see you see it can't clear I miss
that now I can't believe in me
I see so then we're gonna go where's
Agrippa
is somewhere I forgot okay
launch the back
here it is annoying Timon I'm sure
there's a gripper but we're gonna head
up here and I don't know if you remember
this but there's like a well or
something up here
whether scary monster is yes so we're
gonna go there just why not
[ __ ] I hate the Lord's happening - this
place is disgusting goo everywhere I
don't like you
how much more laughs let's go
and I think we're really close to
finishing the game now I hope at least
oh yeah can do this in oh [ __ ] hope this
doesn't hurt me - it'll set
jumping works apparently oh let's cover
it up I thought you were gonna do with
it okay
my character is talking to himself he
can even pee his pants
it's pretty funny you can't yeah I I
haven't noticed it but someone else
noticed that like a piss sound started
it's pretty funny okay so let's put this
there and let's feed the fish
fine how do I do this
there we go you wrote it but yourself oh
[ __ ]
you really like that okay let's there's
something pulling the rope yes hold up I
can't that was really creepy music oh
look at that it's not a nothing left
than book but bones I guess we got
remains bone-in covered covered in mucus
let's see if we have all this stuff now
which one is it
um
ritual no Irish it's gotta be notes no
it's a greatest channel note there is to
release a group without killing him
where you told me to feed him a tonic
made from a paralyzed by a and yeah okay
so we need a poisonous funghi we already
have that and we need Oh
missing something
yeah we are
no we don't know no we have the blood
well yeah you took up the blood from the
well yeah and then let's go back to the
laboratory and try yeah it's probably a
good idea I just want to see if I have
all this stuff because it'd be annoying
if I have to go and look again I get the
feeling that I am gonna do that so
whatever yeah
and I'll remember but I played some game
sometime yeah I'm not like run back in
watch every corner yeah it sucks being
stuck like in the old days when you were
little you couldn't check internet when
you get stuck
and I was annoying I guess so we have
the weather did a blog go though didn't
we put blood here no there it is
there's the blood you think it will work
if we put the bone there yeah it did
awesome
good we're on track
oh and the ponies gone that was quick
so now we're going to use it on the
poisonous thing and hopefully this will
complete our tonic Wow
a green tonic yeah we got it
awesome 316 we got the way you're Sonic
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa mr.
monster
I hope not man it would suck so hard if
he
yeah we did it no here touch
first feed me the tonic and then use
what that's 20 cookies whoever you'll be
able to cut off my head
are you reading this yeah Cathy said
Alexander is open wonderful
I was glad to like walking we only need
his head apparently yeah you saw this is
gonna be hilarious
okay so feed him the tonic I feel feed
him the tonic quickly and now we're
gonna saw his head off
yeah I'm glad I don't have to see that
yeah haha dude forget it where's your
hater hey where's your hate a case I got
look at his face
Oh uh-huh
that's quite a tonic Salih someone's
head and then but like I was supposed to
go to the portal thing the orb is needed
to enter it shadow pieces yeah we know
that we have all the pieces a mystic
barrier blocks a passage in the comms oh
yeah
we know that also so I guess we're going
to go in here the console chancel
something at least she cried and
struggle as he pulled at her arm her
flowered Sunday dress ripped and she
fell into the mud I think that was
Daniel who did then it doesn't matter I
guess I feel like something scary is
going to happen here remember the last
time when I opened this door and the
monster killed me
he didn't kill anybody putting me to
prison No
let's just stick you nice and slowly
I get the feeling he's here are you
watching oh oh whoa winds not good never
good news whoa whoa whoa whoa stop that
how do I avoid getting damaged from the
getting hurt or whatever jump
okay let's hope he's nothing here the
door just left open that's never good
news
hello what
okay hopefully we can place the pieces
here yes we could awesome
and a decimal I guess that's the tar
yeah it worked
am i doing it wrong no no this perfect
oh [ __ ] I'm nervous as [ __ ] now we got
them working it is like when your entry
pass itself I don't want to go in there
yes Oh what
Oh what did it say do I need something
else
nope just not by itself remove the
barriers something must be done with the
machinery it's I know what the machinery
is but I don't know what to do with it
oh I still holster over there I was
gonna cry
the machinery is over there but like we
have no items left so I feel like
there's an item with miss ouch
hope the monster is new tonight I think
we are actually but I think you're after
water
I have to do something with the
machinery to open the portal and the
machinery is down here and the last time
we were here we didn't figure anything
out
so yeah let's see what is not working
ouch I'm guessing we're gonna stop the
machinery yeah
with a pole no they were used to bone
good hey we don't have the hammer and we
need like a pipe or something to shove
it in it
Oh
oh no it didn't work it's not large
large enough to jam so we need something
bigger like we
now I can't take it up
or pick it up for whatever so we need to
find something else yeah uh yeah why not
that'll be nice bugs do you think that
will fit maybe a stone
you think they'll simple work I don't
think it will
No whoa we did work good job
this doesn't make the machinery work
right yeah true I hope we don't have to
run in there oh [ __ ] he's coming over
ye hmm no [ __ ] you and I hide yeah yeah
good yeah this is good I camp in a
corner [ __ ] yeah there was no creepy
music there's always creepy music
warning you I knew he's gonna come here
he's like oh what's going on here ah
[ __ ]
how long should I wait yeah I'm always
too quick you never see him he looked
different though I think there's another
one
maybe I'll grip us buddy I hope not
well I hope that do you really wanna go
it's gonna shake the corner
well doo doo doo decision oh it's not
[ __ ] funny can I close the door no
there is no door to close
just go up me no I'm not gonna go up if
he sees me I'm [ __ ]
okay let's take it nice and slowly hello
he's gonna be here you know
oh [ __ ] wait wait what any turn off the
lights huh okay I really hurt Jamie the
scary [ __ ] I think he's gone actually oh
[ __ ] today let's take this hammer throw
it in his face dude
ah he's gone
I would not be surprised if he teleports
behind me
okay let's just [ __ ] run for it
run run run oh [ __ ] who puts up blue
flames in the chamber yeah but it might
doesn't it change color depending on
pressure or something it might be higher
pressure down here so that changes it
colour or something maybe probably not I
don't think you'd let deep down where's
that warp it is feared okay yeah anyway
whoa no no no no no no no no no no no no
what's wrong something creepy is
happening
inner sanctum oh that's scary yeah